I also invite you to participate in the
david pakman show subreddit nearly 6,000
of our viewers and listeners regularly
discuss and debate politics there a few
interesting discussions that I saw this
morning when I browse david pakman.com
slash reddit 1 is a post arguing that
the left doesn't take anti-semitism
seriously and the post specifically
relates to the vile and toxic
anti-semite Louis Farrakhan Farrakhan
I'm not even sure how to pronounce his
last name but big picture I've talked
about this issue before I do think that
there is a problem on the left of not
taking anti-semitism seriously there's
the idea that Jews are doing great in
the United States and so even if there
is any kind of antipathy towards Jews we
don't really need to worry about it and
it's a very very easy way to minimize
anti-semitism and I generally do agree
with that so yes very interesting
discussion also from the David Pakman
show subreddit a poster says I honestly
enjoyed the David Pakman show but does
anyone else think he can be very
condescending to callers and guests and
interestingly just about everybody who
responded the depth of this said no I
don't think David is condescending to
the guests I think that David is very
direct with them if they're wasting time
or if they're not getting to a question
or if they're filibustering but you
should watch other shows if you think
David is condescending to guests
I I don't you know listen I'm not gonna
baby if you're choosing to call into a
show and make a political claim I'm not
gonna treat you like you're a kid if I
disagree with you I will tell you if I
believe that you're not defending your
assertion I will tell you and if I think
you're wasting my time I will also tell
you but it's not like people are victims
when they choose to call into the show
and make a point right I I don't know I
I tend to disagree with sometimes we're
a little too respectful I would say I
argue the same thing when I allow
someone to go on for two minutes without
asking any questions and then eventually
I say listen you're killing me I got to
get the question from you it's my
television though sure I don't disagree
but it also is necessary we got to move
the show along right also from the David
Pakman show subreddit is there a way to
be pro-israel and not support Benjamin
Netanyahu yeah you just say I believe
Israel should exist in
a valuable project and I am against
Benjamin Netanyahu I mean it's it's sort
of straightforward I think maybe the the
better question or maybe the implicit
question here is is there a way without
supporting the current regime to still
be seen as a supporter of Israel and I
would argue it depends who you ask
because there are definitely extremist
right-wing elements who see anything
short of total support for Benjamin
Netanyahu as being against Israel yeah
and yeah I mean the answer is very clear
and resounding yes feel like you've been
doing it for a long time pro-israel anti
Benjamin Netanyahu please please and
thank you I appreciate that uh I wasn't
gonna pat myself on the back but if
you're gonna point out that's my
position I'll gladly accept it also from
the david pakman show subreddit a very
interesting article about how the nra
and its allies used jargon and semantics
to bully gun control supporters this is
very very true and one really good
example is that because the ar-15 rifle
has played a role in so many mass
shootings it's become popular for the
pro-gun right to ask people who believe
ar-15 should be banned if they know what
AR stands for and many people will say
yeah it stands for assault rifle 15
which is wrong AR stands for light
Armalite the company that made the first
of that style rife I don't think this
anymore yes that's correct
but it doesn't matter right I mean the
article is very good because it points
out that it doesn't matter whether you
know what AR stands for you can still
think that it should be a weapon that is
or isn't banned right and it's a very
very interesting article that someone
posted to our subreddit and I encourage
you to check it out and you can
participate in all of these great
discussions at david pakman.com slash
read it